a walmart in the north valley closed
tonight taking shoppers by surprise is
the walmart on north decatur and the 215
closed for cleaning but it's not clear
if it is due to covid19 while we did
share the announcement with our viewers
shoppers also telling victoria saha they
were really caught off guard
this parking lot is probably the
emptiest you'll see me see it because
shoppers tell me that this lot is jam
packed every single day there's
definitely some concern from shoppers
walking all the way to that entrance
only to be turned away
the store temporarily closed at two
o'clock the announcement sent to eight
news now says the reason for the closure
is for a third party to clean and
sanitize the store this will also give
employees a chance to restock the
shelves i caught up with shopper arielle
williams she walked out one minute
before closing she says she feels like
she had to rush out
we were like oh i wish someone would
have told us that they were doing that
we kind of just got things that we were
like okay we know where this is
i reached out to walmart for specifics
on why this location was chosen for
sanitizing was it due to covet cases or
something else and if more locations
would close and be cleaned in the coming
days i'm still waiting for their
response but there is good news this
location will reopen back up saturday
morning at six o'clock reporting live
near 2 15 on north decatur victoria saha
8 news now